is the uk facing a second surge of
coronavirus the latest data out from the
government suggests well it looks pretty
worrying 938 cases rising to the highest
level
since early july and if you look at it
as a percentage of the population well
here's what you see
you can see confirmed covered 19 cases
per hundred thousand the population
up to the highest level in around a
month just over a month
uh actually but here's the thing over
that period
the number of tests that have been
carried out has also gone up up by about
22
and the more you test the more likely
you are potentially to get positive
results so what we really want to do is
not just look at that line which is a
percentage of the population
but look at a different line as a
percentage of the tests
carried out and you can see similar but
subtly different rather than kind of
going up to the highest level
since july it's been broadly flat for
most of
july so you look at it this way
crucially as a percentage of tests
you aren't seeing a massive surge but
clearly there are hot spots across the
country and let's look at
a few of them this map just shows you
different local authorities in england
and the darker the area the higher the
level
of covert 19 that has been detected
there so let's zoom in and look at
leicester over 100 cases
per hundred thousand and then around
manchester
you can see blackburn 147 the highest
level there
uh bradford oldham as well and
interestingly actually uh south and the
southwest in swindon
we're also seeing a rise so 67 cases per
hundred thousand
in swindon so are these real problems
well let's have a look at them on a
chart and you get a pretty good sense of
that so
this line shows you england across
england uh cases per hundred thousands
of the population
and have a look at leicester it's an
enormous increase in comparison
uh with the rest of england similar
story in blackburn that's now
uh up although leicester's come down
blackburn's uh risen slightly higher and
then
oldham uh and then swindon there it is
so swindling's starting to rise but
i suppose the question is are these
because testing has increased
or are they genuine surges and the short
answer is
we don't really know because the
government doesn't release testing data
how many tests have been carried out
for each of these local authorities it's
one of the many problems with the
testing data
which means we don't have a full sense
of what's really going on
in these hotspots nor do we have a sense
that track and trace is beginning to
work
uh properly sage says that there needs
to be about 80
compliance so 80 of the contacts that
someone who gets covered 19
uh and passes those contact details on
80 of them self-isolate now
in the first few weeks of track and
trace they did meet that target but in
the
last few weeks they haven't so concerns
with track and trace
and concerns with the level of the data
we're getting on testing as well